así el heredero que más ha esperado de
la historia del mundo a la edad de 73
años carlos tercero como se le conocerá
es la persona de más edad en subir al
trono británico ha tenido toda una vida
de preparación y los signos de un lento
traspaso de poder se han mostrado
durante varios años a medida que la
reina envejecía carlos representaba el
reino unido en más y más viajes al
extranjero y ayudaba a su madre en
varios compromisos reales importantes
como la apertura del parlamento en
westminster fue él quien recibió el
presidente francés emmanuel mccomb en
londres en 2020 para conmemorar el
aniversario número 80 del llamamiento
del general de gaulle a resistir a los
nazis el 18 de junio su aumento de los
compromisos públicos en los últimos años
cada vez le hace más simpático al
público británico su imagen pública tocó
fondo tras la muerte de la princesa
diana en
1997 ya que muchos lo culparon del
divorcio varios años antes su
infidelidad
a la luz en 1994 catapultando a su novia
de la infancia camila parker bowles al
centro de atención antes de las
revelaciones su matrimonio era visto
como un cuento de hadas para muchos pero
las grietas aparecían durante una
entrevista televisiva ahora famosa
estás enamorado sí mucho lo que sea que
significa estar enamorada
a pesar de su privilegiada educación
carlos supuso muchas primicias para la
familia real nacido en 1948 solo tenía
tres años cuando su madre se convirtió
en reina tras su ascensión su
preparación para reinar comenzó
oficialmente
carlos rompería con la tradición y
asistiría a la escuela en lugar de ser
educado en casa pero sus años en el
internado de gordon town serían
infelices atrapado entre el acoso de sus
compañeros y su dominante padre se
convirtió en un hombre discreto y tímido
aunque seguro de sí mismo siendo el
primer miembro de la realeza en asistir
a la universidad carlos encontró su
hogar en el teatro pero su verdadera
pasión sería el medio ambiente una causa
por la que sus campañas a veces lo
metían en problemas rompiendo con la
etiqueta de mantenerse al margen de la
política sus esfuerzos por frenar el
cambio climático lo han llevado a
reunirse con activistas como greta
tamberg que carlos sea el primer
divorciado en convertirse en monarca tal
vez es un símbolo significativo la lenta
modernización de la monarquía vínculo
entre las generaciones pasadas y las
futuras carlos tiene la ineludible tarea
de seguir los pasos de su madre una
mujer casi mundialmente adorada y
admirada
[Música]